pal Emily companions in studio
we're going to talk about
sports for a minute because
they've been making a lot of
headlines this week and what
happened was. Aaron Rodgers,
another super honk his fancy to
super hunger out I know it's
not your style based on the
face you just made wow
the listeners if you're
watching on FOX nation you just
saw something else Emily just
threw a challenge
flag that yeah you ago Aaron
Rodgers now there's a real
super hog and Emily goes.
>> Well anyway. Aaron Rodgers,
this is what happened then is
vaccinating he has tested
positive for covid and of
course we wish him well nothing
but the best. But he's an
interesting situation because
he had told the league he was
vaccinated but he wasn't
vaccinated he got what he
considers to be a homeopathic
treatment and when he was asked
by reporters are you vaccinated
he actually said that he
actually said the words I want
to give a specific term right
John do you know what it is he
goes. I am in not delay know
and IM mean a nice yeah enough
which reporters took to say oh
he doesn't know how to say an
ocular added he's saying I'm
immunize them vaccinated when
in fact he wasn't vaccinated so
he has spent the better part of
the last 4 or 5 months
on NFL sidelines, not following
vaccine protocols. And now he
has in fact gotten covid but
when I guess I'm trying to ask
you Emily.
As we now living in an age
where we use the chalk or bars
to get into research aacr ID to
get into bars, I mean people
like a bar in sisters.
>> To say you're 21.
>> Is that going on now people
like almost like chalking their
vaccine to get places in life
like giving people are faking
being vaccinated be on Aaron
Rodgers like is he symptomatic
of something else going on in
society right well first of all
yes I was literally 27 in
college as an 18 year-old
because I had my oldest sisters
I really was brilliant it
clearly worked and that's
why not secondly, yeah
absolutely and in fact we're
seeing widespread fraud that's
being prosecuted on the
criminal level of people who
exist in Rome's of law in the
medical field and more which
are making a living.
Frankly, a good likelihood
based on black market
vaccination cards but I think
what's interesting to me
is the notion that this is the
carve out exception to medical
privacy. So we sat here a few
years ago or on on the sideways
beside a few years ago and
talked about to remember when
Jason pierre-paul yeah after
July 4th rate has had a singer.
All of a sudden those records
that was a tremendous uproar
because his hip or records were
published on social media and
rightly so
he was he he should have had
ultimate privacy medically and
professionally in that realm.
And that's the bleed over into
professional sports at what
time does at what point does
your medical history or medical
choices, sort of factor into
the gambling world that the
performance world et cetera and
now with covid that's a whole
nother earlier where people
feel absolutely. Inclined and
they feel entitled to the
status of your vaccination so I
think it's interesting with
Aaron Rodgers in terms of like
with people
literally having to do a
complete like what are those
boards where they have that the
strings, you know you never
won. He was close contacts, but
he didn't wear a mask and then
here he was listed by tracing
it right because at its heart
right, it's not technically
publishable or at least it's
not readily and yet people can
infer or like a deuce
where whether you're vaccinated
or not and now what he's
getting the blowback for is for
quote misleading yeah but did
he and like I feel like to to
us the question is does the
press equal.
And do equal
his employers and should there
should those boundaries and
barriers be Finkel is Einhorn
Iran's clerical I'm just has
been touring what you said now
because I know I get it made
sense.
>> Emily company is in studio.
It's very say that because I
think right now. Everybody
does feel like they are
entitled to everyone else's
medical information and it's so
weird to me that it's like how
we got there as quickly as we
did you know this hasn't been
an erosion over the course of
20 years has been an erosion
over the course of a few
months, you know, even with the
mandate they were telling us a
few months ago I would you
crazy the mandates pretty
psychotic but the Aaron Rodgers
thing I still think you should
be allowed to play because as
you if you follow the NFL.
And you know that the Chiefs
defense that so they're playing
this week
has been socially distancing
from opponents
all Yahoo not yeah they've lit
up 220 points in like 7 games.
So hard that is to do it.
Everyone is like scored on the
Chiefs but I get it and there's
a protocol but it's crazy
because it's like it's one of
those things.
>> You know where sports.
They can't nothing can outrun.
Politics now you know what I
mean from a protest level I
just mean because the covid
thing is infiltrated everything
we've done how excited are you
going to be as a sports fan.
When we're really back to
consuming sports is purely
sports. Boos heckling
cheerleaders games, you know I
know is that I do and I don't
know when that's going to be
because it seems lately that
there's always something
prevent teen that purity right
first it was a certain
political agenda that we're
seeing on the field by the
players.
>> That then resulted in
member season ticket holders
literally sued over the right
to enjoyment of of tickets.
I mean there's a lot going on
between the fans and the owners
and the league and the unions
and we saw playing out on the
field we saw people boycotting
with their televisions
and then now it's bled over
into covid in the lake so there
it seems to be that there's
always something that's making
people turned off about the
game rather than being stoked
about it and I think you know
to your point about the readily
like just it just just regret
to saying the information you
tell your uber drivers in the
elevator. The other day.
The 20 seconds with a with an
elderly gentleman and I asked
if you mind if I got in with
him and he was like we have
course unvaccinated I presume
you are too you know it was
like yeah, I mean
I I I give that private medical
information to strangers within
4 seconds
I want to tell them my name I
want to tell them anything and
yet that for some reason to
your point is this bit of
information that we'd like
scarlet letter. You know for
for good or for bad
on ourselves in an instant so
world changed with that and for
those that feel a certain way
about it that went to have
privacy. We sort of have
potentially criminalize or
ostracized. Their right to
privacy frankly that was a rate
that we have
culturally protective
of and now all the sudden it's
gone and all of us that in a
place that on the field and all
the sudden to be written into
league rules man, it's crazy,
you know the co covid all the
sudden it means a forfeit it
means the players pay
penalties, there's so much
going on that are affecting
these guys this man is and